[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans les studios du
figaro on est en direct c'est figaro
live et on attend vos points de vue vos
points de vue en particulier ce soir sur
l'hommage qui a été rendu à samuel pâtit
hommage rendu ce matin à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans le collège
où enseigner le professeur mes hommages
réduit ailleurs pour cause de crise
sanitaire avec en plus une polémique à
la clé sur le texte au lu aux élèves un
texte de jean jaurès raccourci est
modifiée on en débat ce soir avec judith
waintraub bonsoir je dis grand reporter
au figaro magazine et merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation au pied levé on
est heureux de d'avoir le retour
également sur ce plateau de charles
beigbeder bonsoir bonsoir
alors il ya on avait très heureux de
vous accueillir on rappelle que vous
êtes entrepreneur est aussi militant en
signant là on signalera parmi vos
oeuvres alors charnellement de france
aux éditions pierre guillaume deux roues
et notamment la création d'une volt cas
le filtre avec votre père frédéric oui
on a besoin on regrettera l'absence au
soir de laurent alexandre qui interdit
de quitter la belgique où il réside pour
cause de fermeture des frontières en
cette période de co vide alors question
pour les petits commerçants pour les
mères qui ont signé des arrêtés en leur
faveur en tous les cas les petits
commerçants qui viennent des boutiques
jugés non essentiels le gouvernement
pouvait-il faire autrement remettre en
cause l'ordre de fermer édictées par le
président de la république la semaine
dernière là aussi on en débat mais
d'abord on va revenir donc sur l'hommage
qui a été rendu à samuel pâtit
aujourd'hui et voici ce que les
enseignants ont notamment été amenés à
montrer ce matin extraits c'est un
honneur pour moi de rendre aujourd'hui
hommage au professeur samuel pâtit
devant vous sa meule patty a consacré 5
l'iedom à la plus belle des missions
éduquer les jeunes dans le respect des
lois et des valeurs de la république
dans lesquelles il avait froid et pour
lesquels il a donné sa vie au long donc
la mémoire de samuel pâtit héroux de la
laïcité
le pâtis euros de la laïcité judith on
craignait beaucoup de troubles ce matin
au sujet de cet hommage
finalement alors je sais qu'on signale
dans quelques endroits notamment à
nantes des problèmes mais des éléments
extérieurs
mais visiblement ça c'est quand même
plutôt bien passé écoutez il faut
attendre d'avoir tous les retours parce
que on s'aperçoit dans ce domaine là que
la transparence n'est pas encore la
règle bien lissés creusot je crois qu'il
y avait un temps songé à rendre la
minute de silence
facultative optionnel qui a ensuite été
aperçu que ce n'était pas du tout l'idée
donc un cas rétropédaler oui ça va dans
le bon sens si finalement on voulait la
rendre optionnel et que finalement les
férias relance et d'avoir un bilan
documenté pour dire que ça s'est bien
déroulé charles une vidéo de robert
badinter un texte de jean jaurès une
minute de silence vous êtes content
qu'on ait proposé ça vos enfants par
exemple maintenant bas le texte de jean
jaurès oui parce que c'est un texte qui
nous on peut vibrer l'extrait qu'on a on
vient de voir de robert badinter est
plus abstrait un peu conceptuel c'est
toujours le problème quand on veut
parler des valeurs de la république
je pense que et de la laïcité c'est je
suis pas sûr que ça parle pour les
jeunes et encore moins les enfants en
revanche si vous leur parlez de la
france de l'histoire de france de notre
culture de notre civilisation millénaire
là ça commence à vibrer oui et je pense
que c'est l'erreur qu'on fait trop
souvent
évidemment c'est l'éducation nationale
peut-être que dans les écoles privées
même sous contrat on a parlé un peu plus
de la france mais voyez c'est je crois
que ce professeur d'histoire il parlait
de la france heureusement et il aimait
la france
il en parlait j'étais troublé dans tous
ces hommages c'est même le discours
présidentiel et d'autres hauts
personnages de l'exécutif
ces sept parfois on a parlé de la france
on parle de la république tout le temps
mais c'est quoi la république
ce n'est qu'un régime s'il ne s'y ne
s'enracinent pas dans une histoire dans
une culture sais rien donc je crois
qu'il est temps de réenchanter la
république et de parler de la france
vous citiez mon ouvrage charnellement de
france c'est évidemment tout la thèse de
prendre en 400 pages donc désolé d'en
parler et on le recommande n'a pas du
tout elle recommande c'est chez pierre
guillaume d'euros ça me paraît un peu
lapidaire à la république est fondée sur
des principes liberté égalité fraternité
la république est laïque précisément
elle le dit dans dans les premiers
articles
on ne fera pas de sa définition
je pense que je vais pas non plus la
ravaler au rang de mode de gouvernement
ça veut dire quelque chose mais en fait
vous avez raison et puis on peut faire
les deux mais obligés de choisir entre
la france et la république
moi je pense est un autre élément vous
avez raison de dire que la laïcité peut
être un concept un peu difficile à
appréhender un peu théorique dans le
cadre d'une
d'un exercice très formel comme ça il y
avait des choses beaucoup plus faciles à
appréhender est beaucoup plus brutale
par exemple de rappeler le fait que
samuel patty a été vendue par un certain
nombre d'adolescents il t'avait 14 13 ou
14 ans et ça ça ça peut parler
je pense donc en s'appuyant sur une
morale qui est aussi bien la morale
républicaine que chrétiennes et la
morale de toutes les régions ne vend pas
bien sûr c'est les 30 deniers un christ
évidemment quelle tristesse que ces
collégiens étaient manipulés et céder à
cette tentation mais vous y voyez
justement à travers à travers cet acte
de collégiens qui ont qui ont vendu qui
vont laisser qui se sont laissés
remettre de l'argent donc contre la
fondation d'accepter ce marché une
dérive directement morale aujourd'hui et
qui devront faut qu'il soit très
lourdement sanctionné pour ça parce que
ce faisant alors je ne sais pas quel
sera in fine et le chef de mise en
examen ou deux le motif peu retenue par
le juge qui sera chargée d'instruire le
procès ils ont contribué
involontairement à ce que le meurtre
soit commis on parlait tout à l'heure
de céline pina en tout cas d'une tribune
quel signe dans le figaro aujourd'hui où
elle révèle justement cette cette
hésitation qui a eu dans un dans un
établissement scolaire du creusot pour
rendre cet hommage qui finalement a été
rendue sous sous sous pression céline
pina donc qui est militante ancien
militant du parti socialiste et
militante laïque
aujourd'hui anciennes habitudes ce
prades plateau s'en prend à ce qu'elle
appelle le sentiment d'un préparation de
flou et désinvolture d'une
administration pléthorique qui paraît de
plus en plus incapable de toute réaction
à la hauteur
elle fait allusion au fait que dans un
premier temps il était prévu qu'il y ait
un hommage aujourd'hui que tous les
élèves de france et de navarre entre à
10 heures pour rendre hommage à samuel
pâtit et puis finalement ils sont
rentrés à 8h et que l'hommage et que
leur qui doit être consacré à cet
hommage et à cette réflexion ne pas
forcément lieu aujourd'hui mais jusqu'à
la fin du mois de novembre
jean michel blanquer le ministère de
l'éducation nationale invoque les
contraintes sanitaires et sécuritaires
ça peut s'entendre quand même non je
vois pas tellement ce que les
contraintes sanitaires change au fait
qu'on fasse classe une heure sur
l'assassinât de sa mère pattie ou qu'on
fasse cours sur cours normal sur sur
autre chose je vois pas tellement en
quoi ça bouscule non mais c'est
simplement de toute façon on peut
s'entendre sur le fait je crois que
ni une minute ni une heure ne suffiront
et bien sûr à renseigner ce qu'il est
nécessaire d'enseigner pour que ces
actes lâches ne se reproduise pas il est
possible qu'elle quand même eu des des
inquiétudes sécuritaires parce que
sécurité sanitaire pas sali termes
sécuritaires ça c'est vrai que la
semaine a été chargée en événements
tristes mais rorys le nouveau à son plus
haut niveau de risque
donc c'est possible qu'il y ait eu un
arbitrage en ce sens ensemble pendant le
week-end il y a aussi une politique sur
le caviardage de jean jaurès on n'a pas
donné le texte officiel un passage il
appelle à plus d'autonomie pour les
professeurs et qui remet en cause le
recours systématique à la notation
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à juba je
trouve ça assez assez assez drôle en
fait évidemment jean michel blanquer
l'avenir de l'éducation a vu ça comme
une mise en cause de ce que sont ces
principes fondamentaux à lui et a jugé
que ce n'était pas utile de donner des
armes c'est à ses détracteurs
on met du coup ça ça déclenche une
polémique qui est comme vous le disiez
s'ajouta déjà la polémique de
l'organisme reçoit de la réduction à une
minute de silence
il ya une séquence très brève de ce qui
était prévu au départ il y avait quand
même l'objet je crois qu'ils avaient
l'option donc il y avait la vidéo de 3
minutes et la vidéo de sept minutes ou
s'il ya une lectrice qui lit la lettre
très bien c'est une lettre magnifique on
l'a entendu lors de l'hommage à la
sorbonne donc connaître la france
encore une fois son corps et son âme
donc en revient sur le charnel est rom
découvrir la civilisation s'ouvrir à
l'infini moi je suis pas content que la
version courte parce que vous savez les
enfants à un moment une lettre trop
longue il l'aurait ceinturé je préfère
qu'on se concentre sur l'essentiel de
cette lettre qui est quand même plutôt
le début à mon avis qu'eux
dans le monde cet après midi il y a
également une tribune de jean louis
bianco
c'est une interview et d'interviews part
de jean louis bianco qui dit finalement
on exagère un peu beaucoup les choses
est ce que finalement quand on voit
comment les choses se passent il ya
quand même aujourd'hui on l'a vu à un
consensus sur cet hommage
est-ce que c'est lui de nous par raison
non non non en fait jean lui beaucoup
est passé très près de la porte ainsi
que son numéro deux le numéro 2 de
serveurs la laïcité nicolas à cayenne
parce que vous souvenez peut-être de
lors de leurs différents grave avec
manuel valls qui voulait absolument s'en
débarrasser parce qu ils leur
reprochaient notamment leurs
compromissions leur aveuglement leur
déni
récurrent du danger de l'islamisme de
l'islamisme lui même
ils reprochent précisément à nicolas
cadène de son être pris à elisabeth
badinter qui est quand même une
référence en matière de laïcité bon
manuel valls avait perdu le combat à
l'époque et à cause de propos de jean
castex semblait dire que l'instance
allez voir c'est sa direction renouvelée
jean ribes locaux enfin le tandem bianco
cadène avait peut-être devoir partir
avant l'échéance de son mandat qui est
en avril 2000 va hélas pas du tout et du
coup pour fêter ça je range louis bianco
donne une interview au monde où il
répète que la situation n'est pas aussi
grave
qu'on veut bien croire en parlant
l'islamisme et en allant bien au delà de
l'accueil dont il ne savait rien alors
où il a donné l'interview qu'elle est
réservé les écoles et les lycées à la
cérémonie pour saluer le bâti il
explique alors que ce serait une erreur
de changer la loi de 1905
il a peut-être raison mais surtout ils
qualifient de faute majeure
faute politique majeure l'idée avancée
par beaucoup d'interdire aux à des mères
d'accompagner les sorties scolaires
revêtue d'un voile islamique et il
conteste absolument tout lien il est
cohérent avec avec lui-même il doit son
c'est l'apôtre des accommodements
raisonnables et de du supermarché des
cultures du multi multiculturalisme à
outrance donc bon c'est dommage qu'ils
soient pas mis à la porte tout de suite
en effet ça c'est mon point de vue mais
il a échoué
cette ligne a échoué de a à z et si on
n'entreprend pas rapidement une rupture
à cette ligne ça va finir très mal et
pardon c'est d'autant plus ennuyeux que
en fait lui justifie son existence par
des formations et évidemment le point
sur lequel elle insiste dans l'interview
c'est faut absolument former les
enseignants 80% des enseignants je ne
sais pas d'où ils tirent ce chiffre peu
importe de toute façon il suffit de
poser la question comme ça on a ce genre
de réponse
80% des enseignants ne sont pas formés
en laïcité c'est épouvantable donc
évidemment jean louis bianco propose
implicitement ses bons services pour
remédier à tout ça et ça c'est très très
très embêtant et 7 un mauvais mauvais
signe quant à la détermination de
l'exécutif
en attendant allez bon les bons services
de jean-louis bianco sur la formation
des enseignants sur ces questions là je
vous recommande justement le reportage
qui fait de parts dans le figaro qui est
à retrouver sur le site du figaro sur
jeu sera difficile formation des
enseignants sur sur ces questions sur
ces questions là et tous les problèmes
qui sont actuellement rencontrés je
rebondis sur ce que dit
charles et et un débat que vous avez eu
au début de cet échange sur le problème
du multiculturalisme de jean louis
bianco jean louis bianco il a défendu la
laïcité il défend des valeurs de la
république et d'un autre côté il défend
le multiculturalisme est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un hiatus là justement quand on
défend les valeurs de la république
quand on défend des valeurs de laïcité
et bah ça n'empêche pas de deux les
terriens qui sont laissés aux et par le
multiculturalisme c'est paradoxal parce
que il finit par être même pas un
multiculturalisme et multiculturaliste
ce qui pour vous l'avouerez pour un
président de l'observatoire de la
laïcité est un petit peu étrange
et puis moi je suis pas c'est cette idée
alors j'ai pas encore lu l'excellent
reportage sur moi qu'on a publié mais
cette idée qu'il faudrait former
spécifiquement à la laïcité je suis
plutôt contre normalement tout
l'enseignement que ce soit
l'histoire la géographie la laïcité doit
après nié tout ça au sens où par exemple
je suis contre l'enseignement séparé de
l'histoire des religions les
enseignements qu'on a ce sont tout à
fait suffisant il faut pas faire une
case a pas que comme on ferait une case
à part chez pas pour l'écologie ou pour
le fait des listes non on a sûr que
quand vous lui quand si on va jusqu'au
bout de ce que vous dites quand on
enseigne le temps des cathédrales ou
bien quand on enseigne les croisades
on enseigne également ce qu'est l'islam
et ce qu'elle traitait exactement ça on
vous pose la question je crois pour la
france dont l'histoire n'est pas la
conquête de l'europe par l'islam et
j'avais vérifié sur dans les manuels
d'histoire de 5e
il ya plus de pages sur la conquête de
l'islam de l'europe et ces aller retours
que sur l'acompte que la conquête de
l'europe par le christianisme le
développement du casting c'est quand
même assez dingue
donc ce qui pose un problème culturel
mais un énorme problème culturel
et donc c'est compliqué parce que du
coup on y ce qu'on est et donc c'est
très doux et après comment faire aimer
aux français à la france si elle s'unit
ce qu'elle est et que le découvre donc
vous soulevez à bout de l'énorme
problème du contenu des programmes
notamment
des programmes d'histoire alors
justement on était là dans ce débat pour
les pour les soulever et pour montrer
pour répondre à la question justement
également est-ce que l'hommage est à la
hauteur et on voit bien tout le problème
qu'il ya autour et qui est soulevée par
cette cet hommage et par l'enseignement
de l'histoire en france
aujourd'hui vous êtes majorité à
répondre non et on a un internaute qui
se surnomment de gauche donc sympa c'est
un donc c'est un stations non être à la
hauteur c'est déchoir de la nationalité
tous ceux qui préfèrent leur religion à
notre vivre ensemble il faut des actes
en somme et benjamin nous dit que faire
si la minute de silence n'est pas n'est
pas respectée axel nous dit je suis
d'accord rendre hommage
et puis après on fait quoi est ce que
finalement c'est pas ça le problème plus
profond jaune s'est redonné aux petits
français et à tous les français devant
de façon générale envie d'aimer la
france le soleil simone veil -le disait
de remèdes inac c'est donner aux
français quelque chose à aimer et tout
d'abord lors donné à aimer la france et
c'est tellement ça donc on a on a rien
pas à faire notre petite révolution à
faire revenir le balancier qui est un
peu un peu parti trop loin
d'un certain côté et qui fait que l'on
n'arrête pas de s'auto flageller bien on
ne pourra pas faire aimer la france aux
français et c'est le ce prof d'histoire
et ce débat sur la laïcité c'est ne sont
pas résolus tant qu'on n'aura pas
compris cela un an nicolet d'accord avec
vous charles je préfère quand on parle
de la france plus que de la république
beigbeder a raison nous dit nicole une
ethnie comme cette fois ci sur youtube
du tout dépend de l'âge de 11 ans des
enfants il faut parler de la france
c'est plus parlant surtout aux plus
jeunes
axel sur le site du figaro nous dit
c'est faire preuve de naïveté de croire
qu'on va régler le problème avec des
heures de cours l'idéologie bien plus
forte on reproduit les mêmes erreurs
qu'avec les processus de
déradicalisation votre réaction sur ce
point là alors le processus de
déradicalisation c'est un échec total
mais c'est notamment un échec parce que
les personnes qui prétendaient sont
occupés et ont vu une bonne occasion de
faire des affaires
enfin pour parler crûment donc ça a été
fait en dépit du bon sens c'est une
catastrophe
là on n'est quand même pas dans le même
schéma
d'abord parce que peu d'intérêts
financiers pour les profs enseigner ça
et puis je le répète c c c tout
l'enseignement qui est en cause donc
évidemment on va pas régler le problème
en une minute ou en une heure mais il
faut mais de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs jean-michel blanquer a
commencé à le faire depuis sa nomination
regarder de très près les programmes la
façon dont je suis jamais s'il faut dire
récit national aux robes en nationale 3
c'est une telle querelle théologique que
je veux pas rentrer dedans mais en tout
cas la façon dont l'histoire de france
est racontée et qu'effectivement les
profs
le militant qui met dans la tête des
deux gaves à part ce qui en a beaucoup
une proportion que je ne saurais pas
évalué mais que la france s'est rendu
coupable de tout ce que ce que le
restant de vouloir parce qu'on on
dépasse le temps imparti sur sept sujets
là mais quand même sur ce plan là ce
qu'a dit hier le prêt ministre jean
castex sur justement la coloniser la
colonisation c'est donc quelle est votre
réaction par rapport à ce que tu aimes
il est en rupture avec ce qu'avait dit
emmanuel macron il lors de la campagne
présidentielle lors de son passage
oui quand il avait dit que la
colonisation était un crime contre
l'humanité mais il semblerait que ewan
mc on soit sûr dans ce domaine sur
plusieurs points en rupture avec
lui-même ce qui n'est pas mal d'ailleurs
moi j'ai trouvé très bien son discours
pour ça mais elle pâtit de ce que désire
le premier bilan et je pense que lui
manquerait aujourd'hui approuverait ce
qu'elle dit c'est bien ce que dit castex
sur ce plan simple sursaut alors
justement
on dit c'est une très bonne très bonne
transition avant de la vendre avant de
faire la transition jeu quand même je
cite axel qui nous dit la décision
vis-à-vis de nicolas cadène s'inscrit
dans toute la reculade de macron est
claire nous dit la moe laïcité a été
vidé de son sens vous continuez à réagir
mais on va réagir maintenant à la
deuxième question celle qu'on vous pose
également sur twitter sur la fermeté du
gouvernement concernant les petits
commerces et les rayons de supermarchés
désormais jugés non essentiels
alors le gouvernement a t-il raison de
les laisser fermer il y à une personne
qui répond non c'est anne hidalgo en
tout cas en ce qui concerne les
librairies on écoute la maire de paris
je suis là pour soutenir cette idée
appelé bien sûr à ce que les librairies
réouvre le plus vite possible
le gouvernement a fixé un cap autour du
12 novembre
il faut absolument que d'ici là nos
librairies puisse réouvrir et congrès
autorise tous les libraires à pouvoir
exercer leur métier
nous avons adressé une demande au
gouvernement de réouvrir les librairies
de considérer le livre comme un bien
essentiel alors sans préjuger de la
réponse du gouvernement on peut quand
même imaginer qu'elle sera ferme est
opposé en tout cas si l'on se rappelle
ici on évoque la réponse qui a été fait
et la vigueur avec laquelle elle a été
faite par le premier ministre hier au
plateau sur le plateau de tf
d'abord un non madame nous ne
reviendrons pas c'est certainement pas
le moment de revenir sur les mesures
annoncées c'est beaucoup trop tôt
d'ailleurs je commanderai ouverture dans
l'immédiat de réouverture madame et je
vois même et qu'il faut que toutes et
tous au delà des commerçants que nous
soyons extrêmement vigilant que nous
respections ce confinement il en va de
la survie de l'économie il en va de
notre santé collective cet impératif je
prend pas ces mesures pour embêter les
français je les prends nous les prenons
pour les protéger
alors je prends ces mesures pour
protéger les français disait jean castex
hier 71% des français charles se disent
prêts à passer un noël confiné selon un
sondage pour nos confrères de ses news
cet après midi on peut croire le
gouvernement quand même je comprends pas
je suis pas un professeur de médecine
mais les contaminations n'ont pas lieu
dans les petits commerces ou parfois il
ya une dizaine de personnes qui vont
venir dans la journée
franchement des commerces de ce qu'ils
vendent des vêtements
il ya un moment donc ok les les réseaux
vous produisez des chemises
oui voilà j'aime on commet trop de mon
micro s'en va c'est pas grave je vais
lui apprendre les langues et hélas pas
plus bas les les contaminations mois
elles font c'est pour moi elles se font
surtout lors des repas à la cantine au
restaurant d'entreprise ou évidemment
avec des amis et c est ça donc
et ça c'est malheureux pour les restant
encore qu'on aurait pu les laisser
ouverts pour les repas familiaux dans la
cellule familiale confiné mais mais les
petits commerces
c'est pourquoi s'en prendre eux c'est
complètement injuste et puis alors là
ils ont fait leurs stocks pour noël donc
pas donc c'est la ruine assurée pour la
plupart d'entre eux alors bien sûr il ya
un méga plan financier mais combien de
temps ça va m et le ministre de
l'économie dit oui mais on va même les
aider à se digitalise evo l'ouvrir
gaulle et vous pensez que les les petits
commerçants ils vont se digitalise et en
quinze jours donc c'est je suis assez ou
très 2
cette décision qui est injuste et qui
n'est pas compréhensible alors marco est
d'accord avec vous sur youtube inédit
c'est bien dans la plupart de ces petits
commerces que les mesures de
distanciation peuvent être appliquées il
suffirait de laisser ouvert tout en
imposant une limite de clients à
l'intérieur une limite du nombre de
clients judith mais d'un autre côté avec
la faune si le gouvernement recule sur
ça avec la fronde qui est en train de
monter les maires qui essayent de de
faire d arrêter le contre l'esprit de ce
que emmanuel macron a annoncé la semaine
dernière
est-ce qu'il a pas plus de risque a
reculé qu'à te dire fermer puis dans
quinze jours on voit les choses
dans les deux cas c'est une des
solutions moi aussi je m'interroge sur
les raisons pour trouver solution
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont choisi non moi il
me semble mais c'est une tentative
d'explication personnel que comme le
gouvernement a raté la stratégie qu'il
avait lui-même défini tester tracé isolé
les tests on est seulement en train de
s'équiper de test rapide tracé la
première application fait planter
lamentablement il semblerait que la
seconde marche un peu mieux tant mieux
et pourvu que ça dure en tout cas on en
est que maintenant à lancement la
seconde
et quant à la troisième isolé on ne
parle toujours pas des hôtels qui
permettrait d'accueillir et qui ont
d'ailleurs fait des erreurs des offres
je pense par exemple à un accord auquel
le gouvernement a dit non donc donc
l'entente plantage total de sa stratégie
dont il faut qu'il faut qu'ils fassent
quelque chose ne peut pas rester comme
en suède des filières stratégiques à ne
plus en bouger
et comme il ne peut pas intervenir dans
les foyers même s'il préconise qu'on se
rassemble pas plus de 6 c'est très très
difficile dans le mince que ce soit oui
c'est très très très difficile d'aller
contrôler est encore plus difficile de
sévir pénalisé vous voyez à un flic
rentrez chez vous il dit attention cette
vasque quand vous êtes à deux absolument
impossible c'est très difficile aussi
dans les entreprises dès lors qu'on veut
que l'économie continue donc il faut
faire un truc un truc qui se voit c'est
tombé sur le petit commerce je crois que
ça n'est que ça c'est que le
gouvernement est paumé ne sait pas quoi
faire et a choisi de faire une mesure
immédiatement visible qui est par
ailleurs complètement idiote
oui parce que l'on peut tout à fait y
est allé à noter une deuxième mesure
idiote
au cas où cas où ça suffirait pas
c'est-à-dire d'interdire dans les
grandes surfaces les rayons qui propose
alors là je veux dire que pénaliser tout
le monde les grandes surfaces vendent
aussi des produits fabriqués en france
les grandes surfaces emploi du marché
français du travail à partir de demain
donc tous les produits qui sont jugés
non essentiels y compris le maquillage
puisque c'est ce qu'a répété ce matin le
secrétaire d'état aux pme
alain griset ne seront plus accessibles
en revanche ni dans les petits commerces
ni dans les rayons bazarder la bande sur
vous vous êtes d'accord
babineau qui est un audit
un internaute fidèles de figure là avec
on salue ce soir qu'il dit je comprends
la fermeté de castex d'un point de vue
sanitaire on ne peut pas se permettre de
détricoter un confinement déjà allégé
mais on peut être aussi intelligent et
pourquoi tout décider de la rue de
varenne
pourquoi audi tout décidé pour
l'ensemble des départements français d
honneur au nom d appliquer le traitement
qu'on applique aux métropoles aux
grandes villes aux zones rurales ovale
et mon team de montagne reculées où il
ya un seul petit commerce donnée
essentielle et donc qui fait que les
gens vont devoir faire des dizaines de
kilomètres de routes escarpées pour
aller à la grande surface
donc est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
confiance un petit peu aux départements
aux préfets
pourquoi pas aux élus aux collectivités
locales
c'est ça que je comprends pas dans ce
pays il ya un moment la france elle va
pas bien on le sait il ya beaucoup de
défis mais cela on le voit a péché par
jacques de plats sont tellement
évidentes c'est un jacobinisme sabri
d'ailleurs si je me souviens pourquoi ne
pas confiné marco nous dit pose cette
question assez provoque
pourquoi ne pas confiné seulement les
personnes âgées ou les personnes à
risque la constitution il n'est t'elle
pas inadaptée la situation actuelle je
crois que le problème dépasse la
question constitutionnelle
d'abord parmi les personnes vulnérables
il ya aussi les gens qui ont des
comorbidités ça veut dire que vous par
exemple si quelqu'un est en surpoids
vous allez lui dire vous là vous restez
chez vous parce que vous bien pas besoin
de le dire il le sait de lui même
donc ils sont bien imposés donc
simplement il faut ça suppose inverser
la logique est la méfiance faire
confiance aux français
malheureusement là on n'est pas dans cet
état d'esprit les maires qui ont signé d
arrêter vous voulez vous approuvez où
ils sont irresponsables
oui de malo
moi je veux c'est facile de traiter les
verts de débats go de hurler à l'unité
nationale est vrai chez ou atteintes
chaque fois qu'a mais reprend oui c'est
une attitude ça si c'est un rêve c'est
vrai que les démarches je comprends ce
que voulait dire on peut les accuser de
lingots parce qu'ils savent que leur
arrêté est illégal et donc va être
immédiatement sanctionnée par le
conseiller mais mais au moins ça lance
le débat et voyez on en parle et
peut-être que le gouvernement va faire
marche arrière puisque bruno le maire a
annoncé ce matin et parle d'une
concertation donc espérons que ce soit
pas une mascarade de grand stade en
concertation avec les représentants des
professions pour peut-être une une
réouverture à partir du 12 novembre de
certains petits commerces dans certaines
conditions ou en tout cas qu'on pourra
faire du click and collect est allé dans
le petit commerce / sur rendez vous donc
on peut pas ce prétexte d'unité
nationale demandé à tout le monde de se
taire et d' appliquer aveuglément les
décisions du gouvernement
surtout quand gouvernement en question
c'est quand même beaucoup trompé le un
point je vous demande pas d'être madame
irma mais finalement
on le 12 novembre on sera pas très loin
du 17 novembre le disque car c'est
effectivement dans ce métier il faut
jamais reconnu devant la facilité et
donc le 17 novembre ce sera
l'anniversaire du du mouvement des gilet
jaune d'apprendre une association des
jeunes
est ce que dans cette dans cette
opposition tous les cas très forte qu'on
l'entend et puis effectivement ce défi
qui est lancé par les maires on peut y
voir un mouvement de fronde peut-être un
mouvement d'insurrection comme on l'a
dit yvan rioufol
récemment je pense que le risque existe
alors moi je ne vois pas d'insurrection
vraiment parce que les d'abord les gens
sont 71 71 % est passé de le confiner et
puis et puis démoralisés et puis
finalement quand même assez résigné mais
en revanche je vois une confiance qui
n'a jamais été au rendez-vous d'ailleurs
les français ont toujours trouvé que
leur gouvernement n'était pas à la
hauteur
en ce qui concerne la gestion de la
crise sanitaire contrairement à la
plupart de leurs voisins et là il a
c'est de pire en pire et donc le risque
à mon avis et moi dans l'insurrection
que dans la désobéissance passive quand
les gens vont se dire après tout nous on
dit tellement de bêtises sur tellement
de sujets qu peut-être que c'est pas la
peine non plus de se protéger vraiment
de mettre des vasques vraiment là pour
l'instant ça plutôt bien tenu
selon les périodes il faudrait pas que
le discrédit et l'abus d'autoritarisme
de certaines mesures
fasse que les autres soient moins bien
acceptées qu'elles le font actuellement
jean pierre est d'accord avec vous il
dit également aussi au lieu d'empêcher
tout le monde on faisait confiance aux
gens il ya une dernière objection qui
est soulevée par babineau encore et
j'aimerais bien avoir votre réponse
charles amazon est le grand gagnant de
cette opposition entre les petits
commerces et les grandes surfaces
moi je vais plus loin encore qui peut me
faire des ennemis mais finalement amazon
s'était tout ce genre de choses c'est
pas si mal parce que finalement on a on
a un service aux clients qu'on n'a
jamais eue jusqu'à présent c'est vrai
que ça marche bien
bon alors il ya pas ce qu'ont dénoncé
amazon mais finalement on est tous en
est aujourd'hui on dit alors il ya
heureusement des petits amazon français
dans le bricolage y en a je vais pas
citer les noms dans d'autres domaines
ont peu et je crois que et on a en
france un tissu entrepreunarial des
talents dans le numérique qui font qu'il
faut que ces petits amazon français
deviennent plus grand et ça c'est une de
mes casquettes en tant qu'entrepreneur
est aussi accompagnateur d'entrepreneurs
je crois que la france a tout pour
réussir et raisonnons même européen on
peut imaginer fait créer des gars femmes
européen dans plein de domaines mais il
faut qu'on peut-être qu'on retrouve un
peu plus d'ambition je crois qu'on a
tous les moyens techniques humains
financiers mais parfois on n'a pas la
niaque et ça ça manque un peu peut-être
on est trop humble au fond
en revanche le gouvernement français lui
ne l'est pas parce que quand il fait une
erreur je crois que ça serait bien aussi
de temps en temps de le reconnaître et
d'échanger de dialoguer et dire bah oui
ben là je me suis trompé parce que on
sait pas et il est tout le monde sait
que que personne ne s'est en fait où on
va ce chemin il est compliqué de lutte
conte le vide et mais soyons plus
simples qu'elles sont et ce qu'on peut
rajouter juste une chose c'est que si
amazon donne
fournit un service qui satisfait ses
clients c'est aussi parce qu' il existe
de la concurrence c'est la concurrence
qui voulait que amazon vpc et ses belles
mais oui mais quand on interdit aux
grandes surfaces quand on interdit aux
petits commerçants de travailler on
baisse la pression de la concurrence et
vous allez voir à terme c'est jamais bon
c'était le credo libéral de et simon no
10 et toute centralisation des décisions
pour toute la france alors que des
pouvoirs de décision devrait être remis
à chaque maire regroupement de mer en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il pense
merci en tout cas de cette contribution
vous poser la question le gouvernement a
t-il raison de maintenir la fermeture
des commerces et rayon jugées non
essentielles sur twitter vous avez été
très nombreux à voter seront postés la
question assez tard et vous avez dit non
à 66% par don charnellement de france
sept aux éditions pierre guillaume deux
roues la vodka filtrer les tendances
chez les cavistes encore ouverts juger
puisque le caviste est jugée essentielle
qui s'en plaindra on s'en retrouvera on
se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit merci julie dutil advenu à très
vite sur fear alive
[Musique]